So let's say we have a simple two by two
Matrix.
If you remember we talked about this form.
of a matrix
a x equals B
Where as a matrix X is equal to a vector
and B is a vectors if we multiply the matrix
by the vector will get the B Vector now. This is also related to the
inverse of a matrix which will come
back to momentarily Okay, so
Let's say we have this Matrix.
Square Matrix with components 7
3 and negative 1
and we want to calculate the eigenvectors for
the square Matrix
So this is our Matrix a go to take an
identity Matrix and multiply by the scalar
Lambda.
So let's keep this as they
give it.
Okay.
And then we have the ideal in The Matrix, which we know is one.
zero zero one
We will then multiply this by Lambda.
if you remember from
the X the axioms of
a vectors
we can multiply scalar by a vector we can multiply scalars.
By the way with the Matrix and simply what this will
do is we will substitute the ones with the lambdas.
So this will be a variation of the identity. Matrix
will have Lambda across the diagonal.
0 elsewhere
with this combination
we're going to subtract.
from the
original Matrix a
this Matrix that we have created and we will represent this Matrix as
a as Lambda
times. I
since I is used to represent the
I did The Matrix we're going to represent this Matrix as
Lambda times I
so
next thing we are going to do.
is subtract from The Matrix a
Lambda
times I
in other words the difference of this Matrix.
and
the given Matrix
Okay.
This is that Matrix.
and this product
is that Matrix?
Okay.
The next thing we are going to do.
Is what the subtract these two is to do
the following.
We're going to get a third Matrix.
We have seven minus Lambda.
minus 1
minus Lambda
and then of course the other numbers which are three and
three
and this
we will pass as argument to determine it
function.
So we will take this Matrix.
And then we will take the determinant of this Matrix.
And we've already seen how we can take the determinant
of a matrix it will be.
The product of these two numbers minus the
product of these two numbers.
and then we will get
maybe just copy these.
now
if we multiply these numbers together.
We get the following.
expression
Okay, then we solve we are.
You know do some algebra.
So adding the
minus 7 to minus 9 we get
Negative 16, but we also have to make sure.
to bring the terms with
the high order terms to the front. So Lambda squared
must come here to the front.
And we have minus six Lambda.
And then we get minus 16.
Now here we have.
an unknown variable
that's the eigenvalue. So we need to
find you have to solve for Lambda here.
Of course, we will Factor these two numbers.
to get
let me make some steps here. So this is a
let's call this step one.
subtract
Matrix a from
not the times I
don't have step two.
solve for Lambda
so I'm going to copy this.
expression
We can.
effectively term so we will get
Lambda
Yeah, Lambda minus 8.
and Lambda plus 2
of course is equal to 0.
And then so we will get that we will
have two equations not the minus 8 Lambda
plus 2 if we move them to the other side of the equation this would become Lambda
equals 8.
Lambda equals to so these are our two eigenvalues.
So let's make this step three.
Let's make this step three two, excuse
me from my
Handwriting this is why why you use latex to
avoid?
Having to correct myself continuously step two would
be yeah step two would be to determinant.
Step 2
would be
determinant of that
so determinant of
that
right
so
By the way, I will write this all down in latex. So you don't
have to look at this. It's just faster to go to for
me to hand to this by running.
Now we can do is we can go back to the Lambda times
I Matrix so this one up here.
We're going to plug in the values for Lambda.
Okay.
As a matter of fact, let me copy this. I'm just going to
copy this thing.
So we step four.
So first step four we have these two roots.
We can use either one of them. Let's do.
Let's do it first.
Although the solution work for well will work for either one. Both of
those will give you your eigenvector.
so the step four
So let's just bring this over
here.
now the determinant the difference
of a
and
Lambda terms are times. I
so that's this Matrix. This is that Matrix.
So we will take one of those numbers.
8 and plug in for these values
So we're gonna I'm gonna copy this.
And to replace lambdas with 8.
We have three.
three
this is three and this is negative 9.
it's at
What do we do next we?
we represent this as a
system of equations
so we can find x sub 1 and x sub 2
where x sub 1 and x sub 2 are the values in
the eigenvector.
So step 5.
find
the
I get vectors.
eigenvector
single
we have the argument values we can now find the argument vector.
So to do this we are going to create an
argumented Matrix. So I'm going to take this Matrix.
And we're going to have a square Matrix. Excuse me.
We're gonna have a vector.
0 0
essentially what this?
Equation represents is the following.
we have
we want to solve we want to find the eigenvector. So
basically
the vector
That when we multiply by this Matrix.
gives us
that vector
and so the values of this Vector are unknown and
we will say x sub 1 and x sub 2
x sub 1 x sub 2
so we have minus 1 x sub 1
Plus
3 x sub 2
equals 0
and we have in the second equation 3.
x sub 1 plus negative 9 x
up to equal 0
And like we saw in the linear program example, we need
to solve.
these equations or at least
as you know
eliminally one of them
eliminating one of them. Let me show you what elimination means
so I'm going to once again.
We're going to augment the above Matrix.
If you remember what we said about augmenting matrices, so let me
just copy not gonna make up the whole thing.
When you augment a matrix.
What you do is you you bring these two matrices together and then
you separate them by some vertical line.
This vertical line means there's an equation.
So everything's the right side is an equation everything.
The left side are well.
the variables
these are your variables.
and these are the
the zeros of your equation
What we will then do is use.
the gaussian elimination to find the
X's
so
I'm going to for the time being remove this.
Augmented the augmented part because they're all equal to zero.
and
so in order for us to eliminate
this row
Because once we eliminate the first row the second row then
we have found.
Then we can solve for.
At least just for just one equation. So to do
this we are going to take
Row 1 multiplied by three three times R1
and add that to
row two
and the result of this we will override or we will
good inside R2.
Okay.
So what we're doing is this.
this operation
multiply
3 times negative 1 so multiply 3 3
we will apply to all the terms.
and this equation
so and we actually remove the augmented Matrix so we don't need to
worry about this anymore.
This will become negative 3.
negative 3
This will become positive 9.
Add these two.
Well, I can't call them equations anymore. Let me bring back to zero so
your equations now their equations if we add
these terms together.
What do we get we get well.
Well, everything becomes a zero.
So the result of this.
Edition
this will become this will become the second row.
the second row
in other words after we perform this calcium this
what we're very simple gaussian step.
calculate elimination step
this Matrix
will become
that Matrix
these becomes zeros.
Now we can plug in these values into the
equation.
so remember we have x sub 1
and x sub 2
and we want to know what these are so to do that.
We're going to say negative 1.
X Plus
3 x squared
and these are the values now.
These are the values of x sub 1 x of the
because if we multiply this Matrix will put that
vector.
We will get these numbers.
I need to set this to zero and then solve for x sub 1.
And X up to so minus one
X will become.
or rather what I can do is I can
swap these I can have three x sub
and then subtract
minus
1X to bring this to the other side
So we will have One X.
And we just to simplified the notation. That's just
and sorry. This will be positive One X.
positive One X
and if we just lose the one because we don't put
the constant there when it's 1 then X is just equal
to
X is just equal to 3 times x
It's up to.
That's except one.
and
well x sub 2
so here we have.
our vector
x sub 1 is equal to 3.
Right if we swap the orders.
We get three X2. Anyway, this is
this is the this is the correct eigenvector.
Come back up here.
We will have three.
so x sub 1
x sub 2
now, of course we need to
Do the Matrix times do the vector Matrix Vector
multiplication in one sense? Rhs right
hand side is zero. We can always divide by 3 and get back the
original.
Yes.
Now to so this is now a we have
found the eigen we have found the components for the eigenvector.
now
to we know now we need to multiply this so we will multiply these and we will
get
times 3 and 3 times 1 anyway, skipping
skipping the most the
product and some business we will get this.
third vector
which is equal to 24.
and 8
and what's interesting is that we can Factor.
The scalar eight from this Matrix. So this is now B.
So another way to represent this vector.
is to represent it like so
is to go 8 the scalar multiplied by
times 1
and it turns out this is one of the this was one of the values for
the eigenvalue.
So if you multiply this 8 by 3, we will get 24.
Multiply 8 times 1 obviously we'll get eight.
All right.
This is how you calculate.
The eigenvalues and
I how you find argument that is not eigenvector for a
2 by 2.
very
I don't want to say tedious but you know, you have
to first do the difference find the difference.
of the
Identity Matrix that is multiplied by Lambda.
Then it will get a third Matrix.
So then you have to take the determinant of that Matrix.
Once you take the term of that Matrix you will then you will get
this.
expression
and then you have to solve for laptop and you will get two values two
eigenvalues.